- You want a comeback?
- Yeah.
- All right,
we'll give you another one.
What about this name?
Lindsay Lohan. She's coming back, too.
Well, I love Lindsay,
and "Deadline" reports
that she just signed a multi-film
deal with Netflix, yeah.
And she's already doing a holiday movie
for them called "Falling for Christmas,"
and here is the plot line.
She plays a spoiled
hotel heiress gone skiing
who falls, hits her head, gets
amnesia, and falls in love
with the rugged ski lodge owner,
played by Chord Overstreet.
Okay. I'm watching that.
It comes out in December,
but here's the thing,
LiLo went away for a minute, right?
You know, she was always,
everyone always said she was so talented.
She had her struggles
that were very public.
She went away and now she's
coming back with a gusto.
I am here for it, Lindsay.
I cannot wait. You guys, too?
(audience cheers)
I love her.
- I'm excited about this.
I think Lindsay Lohan is so talented
- Beyond. Hello.
Do you know how many times I've
seen "Herbie" the Love Bug?
Do you know how many times
I have seen "Freaky Friday"
with Jamie Lee Curtis?
- "The Parent Trap."
- "Parent Trap."
"Mean Girls." Come on.
- "Mean Girls."
No, I love her, and I loved her music,
and she's was a good per,
- Yes!
- She's a good person.
She's like nice and cool and fun.
- But you know, but it
says something because for,
she was so talented and
then there was a moment
in pop culture where she
was almost like a punchline.
And that's so sad to say, but
I mean, we all saw it happen.
And then I love that she just
sort of, on her own terms,
pushed pause and then now
is like, "Hey, remember me?
I'm this talented and I am a superstar
and now I'm gonna rule the world again."
I love it.
(audience applauds)
- I was the punchline, too.
I was, and I get it.
And you just have to
keep the most open minds
and open hearts.
So I'm here for this.
- I'm here. We're both in.
(audience applauds)
All right, switching gears,
question for everybody,
what is the hottest hangout
in America right now?
Think about it
- Huh.
- I don't know. Where is it Rossy?
- Well, think about it, in the
50s we had drive-in theaters.
Remember? You'd go, well, I
wasn't there, but you know.
And in the 60s, they went to
the bowling alley, apparently.
- Uh huh.
- Okay.
- I feel like I've been to
drive-ins and bowling alleys,
but go on.
- Well, here's what they say
is the the new hottest hangout.
Refinery29 says it's
going back to the mall.
The mall! Yeah, people
are malling it up again.
Malls are ready, too.
50% of retailers have renovated
over the last two years
and new stores are coming in.
Amazon has a new high
tech style shop. Okay.
And Rihanna Savage X Fenty store.
- Oh yes.
- Oh yeah.
Well that just went into a mall in Vegas.
- Oh, I love Vegas.
- And so I-
- I'm going.
- I know you're going to Vegas.
- I'm planning a girl's trip to Vegas.
- Will you go to the mall?
- Yeah, there's like a big mall there.
Is it like Caesars mall
or something?
- Yeah, uh huh. It's huge.
- But all the stores are so expensive.
I can't, I'm not one of those.
That's not my style.
My clothes are FREECITY
sweatpants and vintage t-shits.
- No, that's true.
- Whatever mall has that.
- Yeah.
- That's my mall.
- Do you love the mall
like I love the mall?
I mean, a place where you
can get like, you know,
a half price Pashmina and
an Orange Julius is like,
well that's where I wanna live my life.
If there's not a Sparrow in
your mall, I'm not going.
- Or like a LeSportSac?
- [Ross] A Lady Foot Locker.
- I want a LeSportSac.
- Yes.
- And a hot dog on a stick.
- Yes, please!
(upbeat music)